[Music]
okay today's guest the great Candace
Owens who just recently launched a
documentary called uh convicting a
murder I watched it last night which was
uh pretty epic and this morning and then
she did one before biggest lie ever sold
she wrote A New York time best-selling
book very hard to become a uh New York
Time Best Seller when your name is
Candace Owens but they had to do it they
had to do it because results forces you
to recognize they're called blackout uh
she co-founded brexit along former uh
Tucson police officer Brandon Tatum in
2018 in 2021 she joined daily wire will
she host a show uh hosts Candace a
political talk show and by the way
you've seen her all over the place
Candice thank you so much for being on
the podcast thanks for having me this is
awesome yes it's great to have you on so
Candace question you know this entire
time you know we're sitting there saying
how do we start the question what do we
talk to her about who were you in high
school in 10th Grade I'm actually
curious oh gosh that is a totally
different Candace I mean I would say I
was probably who everybody was in in
10th Grade you know I was definitely
just trying to figure out who I was I
was skipping classes I was always in
good classes though but I was skipping
them I had a boyfriend who I was
obsessed with you know and so we were
always skipping and going other places
um definitely not conservative but I
would say not politically inclined at
all which is important to State because
people have kind of shifted The
Narrative and said I was like a radical
leftist or something I just didn't care
about politics never voted
um wasn't following it at all but uh
yeah always loved communication Excel
that English and writing and things of
that nature and yeah I mean teachers
would probably say I was a bit of a
smart ass I'd be surprised if you said
that no way they called You Smarter I
was always consistently a smarter I can
see it Canada absolutely yeah what do
you think your your fellow classmates
are saying about you now like I can't I
didn't see this comment or I totally saw
it coming totally I would think they
would say the opposite yeah and my my
parents I mean just I've always been
very sure of myself even when I was
wrong do you know what I mean is that
that makes sense like I have a
two-year-old woman and he's like I have
a two-year-old toddler son who's got
that same characteristic where he's
always very sure of himself even when
he's completely wrong so for you to a
4.5 GPA will you to Four Points I was
like of the 3.5 okay because I just
didn't care got it and that was 3.5
without trying at all when you're
playing sports were you an athlete
cheerleader cheerleader okay big high
school or small High School uh 2 000
people graduated in my high school so
relatively big
more English less math did you like
science hated Math and Science okay
loved English communication so kind of
makes sense that I'm doing an education
um and when I graduated I majored in
journalism in English so words always
just came very easily to me I loved to
read which was uh my dweeb habit that I
developed from the time I could pick up
a book what'd you read back then what
were you reading I was actually reading
all fiction my mom was a part of some
weird book club where she'd just get
like Nora Roberts and Dean Koontz sort
you know and it was just what I was
reading obviously the books were bigger
than my head when I was younger but it
was just what was on our bookshelf so uh
I read through everything my mom read
through I was very into Harry Potter
forget it like a racing home to try to
yeah to try to beat my mom to read the
books when they came out like very into
the Wizarding worlds of Harry Potter
have you ever met him I haven't met him
yet
yet I like that meaning like you plan I
plan to meet Harry Potter nice yeah
maybe we can arrange something yes
Hogwarts action well what house would
you be in did you guys read Harry Potter
no that is deeply upsetting to me every
person should actually read it
it's a really she's a really good book I
mean it's not didn't become this whole
thing because it was a bad book I'm
telling you it's really good what house
are you
I thought you know what I don't wow
yeah
I feel like I would be like hairy like
it would be like between Gryffindor and
Slytherin and then I would be able to
pick my house that's a reference you
that watched Harry Potter yeah anything
that she's talking about but people that
are watching this show do because Harry
Potter was Sensational and they should
place you in a house I want to actually
know that's hilarious yeah Rob can you
ask them
what house they would put him in very
important
they're gonna guess what do you got
what'd you guys think uh Gryffindor is
Slytherin they're gonna say Pat there's
more no there's more houses they could
be but I'm saying they're gonna pick out
of those two main ones he has to be
Gryffindor now I have to go
it could be Ravenclaw oh Ravenclaw
you're just blowing his mind yeah
well Rob why don't you uh first of all
why don't you do this do a poll to see
what percentage of the audience has read
the book so we can kind of get an idea
red or watch the movie I think it's both
counts both counts okay
yeah yeah there's good people in there
so Ken is in in your you know High
School badass like you know you're
getting old you're getting older at what
moment was the political thing hit in
your head like a woman where you're like
I gotta kind of get involved recently I
mean I I guess it's not that recently
anymore but not until Trump came down
the escalator in 2015. and I think it's
because it was Donald Trump he made
everybody even if you weren't
politically inclined you suddenly had an
opinion yeah for sure couldn't look away
yeah so I didn't have there was no
political inclinations in my house my
parents were not politically engaged my
grandparents who I grew up for a good
portion of my childhood in their home
weren't politically engaged so I would
say I came from a very apolitical family
but of course left-leaning because
you're black and you're supposed to be a
Democrat so that's just kind of the
cultural poisoning that goes on and um
in 2015 trumping on the escalator I
remember thinking like I don't want this
guy to win because not because of any
reason other than he's an Entertainer
you know exactly so to me it was it was
like if someone like Hulk Hogan was
running I would just be like I don't
know you know it didn't feel appropriate
after Obama was in office and then I
watched a speech that he gave in
Dimondale Michigan and he made this very
interesting elevator pitch to Black
America and he was kind of just listing
through all of the actual factual
statistics in Black America of like this
is the poverty rate this is whatever it
is and at the end he's just like I mean
did you try something different what do
you have to lose I was like a pretty
good business pitch she's like somebody
saying like I'm the greatest person
everybody's saying look around you
you've been doing the same thing
Democrats 50 years nothing's gotten
better why don't you just try something
different and after I finished watching
it I like remember turning on whatever I
was normally used to watching MSN CNN
and they completely pretended that he
attacked black Americans called him a
racist and he gave the most racist
speech that black Americans were all
living in poverty and it was just such a
blatant lie that I was confused about
why my trusted sources were lying gotcha
and then I kind of started wondering
what the racist side was saying and I
just got curious so we were just talking
about about high school you left High
School you graduated high school and you
went Rhode Island not exactly a Bastion
of conservatism no it's not and then
from there you went to work for Vogue
magazine which was even further left
than the University of Rhode Island so
where were you like on political
spectrum and just thinking maybe you
didn't think of it was political but
where was your thought like when you
left
high school then to Rhode Island and
where did you come to where you are
today well I was I was liberal but I
wasn't crazy liberal like you're never
going to find any old pics of like I had
Republican friends that you know it was
just a different time I think you were
we were allowed to kind of be like oh
like I'm left leaning and right-leaning
and you could it was okay back then that
was okay back then that was totally fine
no nobody actually really cared it was
college and I would say I was liberal in
the sense that if you had just asked me
generally speaking about things like is
feminism good yes just everything just
the checklist of I have had a public
school education you know and I had a
public education so I would have said
yes to this yesterday gay rights all of
these things but not forcefully like
there's no old images of Candace like
wearing a [__] hat or marching yeah it
just doesn't exist I just didn't care
very disappointing more of an answer
than I was what about Obama did you vote
for Obama this no straight up no no so
it's so funny is everyone says that
there because I just didn't care I mean
I was no I shouldn't say that I didn't
care I was so happy when Obama won yeah
because it was black because he was
black or because I mean very simple both
reasons because he's black and because
he's very much flaming
um we're saying Obama wears a [__] hat
to go to sleep everywhere sure I think
it's wonderful and for those reasons I
remember sitting in my room on my
college campus and like crying then I
Obama I'm like okay this means America's
moving forward tears of joy cheer tears
of joy and I you I mean you couldn't not
feel the Obama oh my God it was kinetic
yes we can yeah
how old are you at the time at 15 years
ago you were uh how old
I was in college I remember being my I
think it was my sophomore year about 20
years old so eight so 2008 T's becoming
president you're cannot believe this is
taking place and in the evolution and to
really get into politics doesn't happen
until 2016. yeah yeah and then boom yeah
I went and worked in New York I was
working at a private Equity Firm I was
just like fully trying to get myself out
of student loan debt so it was all about
working for me I was never an idiot I
was always about wanting to get my
finances right I've never not had a job
since I was 14 years old
um my grandfather was very much
impressed upon the Owens you have a job
you work and so for me I just wanted to
get my financial life in order and
coming out of college I had 150k in
student loan debts no money from my
family so it was the pressure to make
money was what my focus was I didn't
really care about
um politics at all 150k where'd you go
to school Rhode Island URI can you
believe that 35k a year and then of
course obviously
yeah yeah there's like 37 000 per year
all right here you go rob got the polls
for you what does this mean wow
Gryffindor they think you're brave
that's the house Harry Potter's in okay
they think you're brave that you have
good values you know with that this
could be a bias plus this could be
biased pool because they're watching
your show yeah
you know wow second though is Slytherin
second that's pretty crazy right pretty
crazy I thought they'd go Ravenclaw but
they went Slytherin yeah so they that
they definitely think you have a
capacity for evil they think that you
could twerk yeah
but you are definitely definitely no
Hufflepuff
okay so let's go into some let's go into
some uh uh current events and then
obviously we'll talk about the
documentary as well we're going to put
the link below folks for the documentary
Rob if you can make sure chat
description everything we have the doc
we'll talk about that uh on this story
but let me first go to our sponsors our
sponsors today is American Hartford gold
we chose to go go with these guys we
looked at a lot of different places as
you know I've been a gold investor for
many years I have physical gold I've had
physical gold for many years a question
you got to ask yourself is this in 2022
central banks globally bought
70 billion dollars worth of gold that's
the most in 73 years what do they know
that you and I don't know so American
Heart for gold what they'll do is
they'll ship the physical gold to your
place or silver directly to your front
door even if it's a gold Ira they'll do
that as well if you have retirement
funds that you cannot cannot afford to
lose this is a time for you to consider
precious metals a deal or I trust
American Hartford gold they'll show you
how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts they have the finest
products amazing customer service and a
bipack commitment they have earned a
five-star rating from thousands of
reviews from an A plus from Better
Business Bureau tell them I sent you
directly and they'll give you up to five
thousand dollars of free silver on your
first order click on the link below or
call
866-939-698-4866-939-6984 or text pbd to
65532 again text
pbd265532 okay so Rhonda santis how do
you think he's doing bad badly without
question why do you think he just has a
personality problem and personality
matters in politics you can't describe
it there's an IT factor that people have
and and it doesn't matter left or right
by the way like Bill Clinton has the it
factor I mean there's just something
about Bill Clinton that even when you
know he's lying to your face you just
like him he picks up the saxophone he
plays it and you feel good about
building so sure like Arsenio Hall when
he did that you know oh yeah I'm like oh
God I know I'm supposed to hate you but
even when Hillary was running I was like
yeah I kind of like this
[Laughter]
Larry Elder was here this weekend but I
I my trainer asked me says who do you
have this week I said Larry Elder
Tuesdays I said Candace on Thursday and
he himself is a former wide receiver
African-American so he's a Greek he says
what is this the pbd podcast
African-American week
that's what we're doing but when Larry
was here we were talking one of the
things we talked about is that I'm
interested in is what are the top five
most important things to look at like in
baseball they used to say it's home runs
or doubles or steal stolen bases or this
and now they're going on base percentage
you know in every sales company you want
to find the number one most important
behavior in content you need Charisma
you know able to keep someone's
attention Storyteller witty entertaining
value all of which you have all of that
so you need those types of qualities
what do you think are the top five
things you need to make a president
worth like you know how Roger Stone said
back in the 70s 80s he says I think
Trump's going to be a president one day
right he said this 40 years ago before
it even happened and then he goes on
Oprah Winfrey's like well you know
you're talking a language you're going
to be one uh one day what do you think
those five things are because the
Santa's has an incredible resume yeah
the resume doesn't mean anything it
doesn't mean anything and unfortunately
people hate to hear that to accept that
as a Truth where it's like well he's
done all these things and this means
that he should be president just doesn't
work like that
um the number I don't say the number one
thing is you got to have the it Factor
you I mean it it and it has to do with
how you warm the crowd how the crowd
responds to you Trump has it I mean I I
when I met him I can't explain it he
makes you feel like he's a blue-collar
person that's been driving garbage
trucks his entire life the way that he
I'm serious I'm not kidding like he the
way he communicates with people you do
not feel that he's this Elite
Untouchable billionaire that comes from
a wealthy family at all and when he
looks at you he wants you to feel seen
he's very funny that's the thing that I
think gets lost is how hilarious he is I
mean he you know he breaks the ice
there's no there's not awkward moment
when you're with him I remember walking
into the Oval Office the first time that
I met him I was so nervous and uh
and one of the worst things oh you know
I love you I watch you on Fox News all
this stuff and then he says you know and
I I want to say also you know you're
very beautiful but I don't want to get
me too I don't want to get me too like
that's very funny for the president of
the United States to say in the Oval
Office at the height of the metoo
movement it's just funny and so he just
is able to relate to people in a way and
I try to tell people he has a Magnetic
Personality and there's nothing that the
media can do to take that away because
if he gets in front of people he's going
to be able to unleash that and DeSantis
has the exact opposite personality so I
saw DeSantis speaking at an RGA before
he was running for
um president and he was speaking amongst
a group of his donors that just got him
elected he barely got over the Finish
Line against Andrew Gillum who by the
way has Charisma has the it factor and
crack there's no reason yeah I'm the one
that broke that story but did you
realize the gay sex party yeah how that
story came to me was you're breaking all
these stories
right time insanity but yeah he almost
lost to Andrew Gillum there's no reason
that they should even be close
of course Rhonda Sanchez is so much
better but what happened Ron has a
personality problem there is he looks
uncomfortable on stage he kind of was
you know snaps at his donors he seems
like he's like angry at them and and
that might be his personality but then
he's trying now as he's running to force
this different personality where he's
like smiling and it makes me
uncomfortable and so I just don't think
he's found his rhythm and his
personality you can find it you think
you can find it you think personality
can be found if you don't have it no
okay so so it factor is one it factors
one what else would you put like one of
the things we talked about is the new
direction of where we're going do you
think the message of anti-establishment
sitting with voters that they're sick of
it from both sides left and right where
Ross Perot was able to be an
anti-establishment Guy where Trump
anti-establishment and you know Vivek
has kind of positioned himself as an
anti-establishment even rfk's kind of
position himself as an
anti-establishment uh uh do you think
choosing the enemies choosing the right
enemies also a factor then do you look
at money like if you have Fu money gives
you an edge where you don't need to ask
money from anybody what else would you
say it is well Instinct I think is a
huge part of it too being able to read
your base and actually being able to
respond and edit yourself if you're
going the wrong way which is something
that All Surrounded sentence doesn't
have like the atmos might have all that
money right and he was the he was the
Blessed candidate all the donors are
giving him all the cash they were
jumping off of the Trump [__] and why
did it not matter because nobody cared
he had very bad instincts you know he
had I was saying I was calling it early
I was like the team around him is
horrible the influencer circle is
horrible I think that the vague is
correct when he says that you should run
your presidential campaign like a
startup and when you talk to any of the
the Trump family members I particularly
I'm thinking of Laura and Eric and Don
Jr they'll tell you how they literally
had no idea what they were doing in 2015
you know because they had never never
done this before so they were kind of
editing and and following their
instincts and listening to people's
feedback so he kind of ran and the
campaign like a startup and when you're
in startup mode which I'm ripping this
from Vivek because we had talked about
this on my podcast you know when you
don't have a lot of money you really
think about how you're going to spend
that not a lot of money that you have
right so you're way more focused whereas
if he said when you're a company and
you've got too much money a lot of it
gets way super packed they get wasted on
stupid stuff because you're like
somebody's telling you pulling you this
way and saying oh you have this much
money you've got to run this on comms
and all of this stuff and Trump was just
like on his Twitter and that was his
comms what else would you say I'm
actually the reason why I want your
Insight because uh I think you flirted
with the idea of eventually running I
think you're eventually going to run I
think you're going to be formidable and
I think if you do it would be so
entertaining to watch on the debate
stage just so for selfish reasons I want
to see it but and I'm sure you've
thought about this because you have that
you have the witty you have the kind of
like you know the Instinct as well you
know how when they're trying to Corner
you you're doing a congress you know
you're out there they're trying to pin
you in this one thing and you come over
here and you call this guy you tell them
I didn't say that and then you they'll
give you a message and you stay on point
while all this shits happen at the same
time you can still keep that voice what
else would you say so so far we have it
Factor Instinct I wrote down naivete an
element of the Tom Brady talked about
the naive factor that you don't know how
dark it is so just like I think I can be
the greatest and then the startup phase
what else would you add to it yeah so I
think that is part of being able to read
the base is actually understanding what
the issues are understanding the people
and this is where the Democrats just
fall apart you know they just become
such elitists I mean in and by the way I
want to be clear not just Democrats
Republicans as well I mean when I was
watching uh the Republican debates and
they're sitting here trying to make me
cry for people in Ukraine are you
kidding me are you kidding me have you
looked around America yet you really
think that this is what the people at
home are going to respond to perpetually
telling them that they have to care
about another Nation more than their own
backyards that they should be carrying
more about what's happening in Ukraine
and Chris Christie trying to pitch it
and you know Pence trying to pitch it
and Nikki Haley you know we need to be
police officers of the world we can't
even police her we can do both no we
obviously can't like have you walked
down the streets of Los Angeles have you
walked down here we clearly obviously
can't do both right and so having I
think that the courage to stand on
something that doesn't feel
establishment popular or mainstream
media popular but that you understand is
what people are actually feeling and you
know I'm very much a person that from
the very beginning has said f Ukraine
you know I stand on that and I I would
have said it if I was in the debate
stage like I would have let them all do
their little pitch in the cries tears
because how this gets into the YF
Ukraine is what I yeah because Rich
because Richmond north of Richmond you
know what I mean that because Richmond
motion because people literally can't
put food on the table you've stopped
people from working in America uh the
average person is struggling to even be
able to afford gas groceries uh you have
people that are dealing with an influx
of crime and illegal immigration in
their cities peoples whose daughters and
kids are being raped and killed that
woman that was horrifically killed in
Arizona going on a run by an illegal
immigrant all this is happening in our
country right here because if you told
me as a mother that I need to care more
about what's happening in the neighbor's
house while my kids were suffering in my
house I would look at you and tell you
you were crazy obviously of course I'm
going to take care of my own house first
and if I have something after my house
is in perfect order right and then you
say to me hey they need help that's
that's just common sense but if my house
is in complete chaos and my kids can't
eat and my kids are struggling how dare
you tell me that it's wrong to want to
care for my own first and that's exactly
what the American foreign policy is
amongst the elites well Candace our
house has never been in perfect order as
you know this in America so how do you
grapple with the fact that when do we
get involved like if China anything
anyway like non-interventional so China
attacks Taiwan you're good with it I'm
what kind of like foreign policy do you
think we should even have zero
whatsoever in the world all everything
that we're doing in the world right now
is were suffering from not being able to
mind our own business this idea you know
post World War II and Inter regarding
International liberalism that it was our
that we must spread our ideas everywhere
and everybody must accept them maybe
people don't want to live like Americans
want to live have we ever thought of
that like maybe people in Iraq and Iran
actually are not interested in the way
that we live maybe people in Saudi
Arabia are not interested in the way
that Californians live and by the way if
you're looking at what's going on in
California and L.A does it seem like
maybe people should be embracing
American values and principles at this
moment like if if you could if you could
buy them and purchase them right now as
another country you probably would be
willing to go the other way hence Uganda
and the laws that they're putting in
place trying to keep this lgbtq agenda
that Americans are funding all across
the world why are we funding that why
are we funding saying that girls in in
Pakistan need to learn about
transgenderism this is the foolishness
that our tax dollars are going toward
and people oh is that because
International liberalism these are great
ideas no that actually these ideas kind
of suck actually sucks and it's
arrogance it's America it's not it's not
even American arrogance because the
average American doesn't think this way
the average American doesn't think that
children in kindergarten need to learn
75 000 genders we aren't even we're not
impressive academically kids are getting
systematically Dumber in America we have
nothing to show for all of the money
that we're spending all around the world
our country is in full decline so I I
actually want to be clear it's not just
F Ukraine it's F everybody until we get
our house in order so nothing you don't
want to be in most of China attacks
Taiwan and the semiconductor chips were
relying on and that's going to be gone
in 96 percent of the products that the
China manufacturing right now in China
were apples manufactured in China and
they go through that mess it's okay it
affects your totally fine to die on
foreign soil zero no not one American
life so so then so then how do you so so
then what would if a Candice Owens was
president today what would your foreign
policies be what would your approach be
with G what would your approach be with
Putin what would you approach be be with
what's going on in Iran or some of these
guys what would you do yeah well I mean
with Putin obviously the worst thing
that we could have possibly done which
is what's happening now is folded him
further into the arms of the East okay
Putin should be a natural Ally with the
West we have been pushing this fake Cold
War for way too long okay we're not in
the 60s anymore okay Putin is not trying
to rebuild Soviet Union uh he doesn't
have the money I mean it's completely
ridiculous to think that Russia is the
biggest threat this is just the
mainstream media simulation it's going
to be just like the Soviet Union whereas
we're the ones that are actually pushing
further into that territory I mean it's
complete delusion we're the ones that is
putting NATO on everybody's border and
pushing and inching further after we
gave promises that we wouldn't do that
that we would not expand one inch
Eastward okay so we're just not being
honest about what it is that's even
happening over there we're not being
honest about the corruption and the
laundromat that Ukraine is and the
reason why we have such a vested
interest in it Biden's interest in it
you know barisma and everything that's
going on this is nothing thing to do
with caring about Ukrainian soldiers if
you actually bought that narrative that
they're worried about the Soviet Union
expansion you're absolutely wrong you
know they just are they want to expand
their own power in that region and so
when Trump was in office and he sought
to have a meaningful relationship with
Putin so that we weren't pushing him
into the arms of China and China is
actually a threat to the United States
uh yeah that was the right policy to
have an actual peace policy you know
that we should be respecting how people
want to run in their own countries right
and also trying to have strategic
relationships strategic Partnerships
with them that's that that is what makes
sense to me I believe in National
sovereignty I believe that Russia has
the right to run its country the way
that it wants to run its country I
believe Iraq Iran America the the United
Kingdom I don't want to be you know we
want to be out we don't want to be a
part of the European Union all the
European Union and these these concepts
of trying to say to globalize us and say
this is how everybody must think we in
America we can't even decide on how we
all want to think you know what I mean
Southern principles and values compared
to New York City and LA is is something
that can't we can't seem to can I give
you perspective can I give you
perspective I want to get your
perspective on this so you know your
daily wire I was just with Ben couple
days ago and we had a good time together
but think about a company for example
that's built on software we rent which
we all do right a company's not built on
100 of software that you have right when
we build an insurance company we
borrowed a company called ipipeline they
are a behemoth of a company two and a
half billion dollar company after 10
years of saying no to him he finally
said let's make it work I said let's
make it work and he came and gave me an
offer I couldn't refuse I said let's
let's roll then another one and another
one I won't name all of them but
my perspective is to say guys moving
forward if you're not one of our you
know a product that we're not doing
internally that's it I don't care about
them we're not going to do any business
this is it this forum we're not going to
do nothing
but we're relying on that software the
reason why I'm saying this is this we're
relying on China okay this we're relying
on China cars were relying on China
today this week was the first time we
got a iPhone 15 that's going to say Made
in India which is phenomenal it's
progress but it's still it's not made in
America right if we do made in America
this is a five thousand dollar phone
this is not a thirteen hundred dollar or
now twenty seven hundred dollars so all
I'm saying to you is from it's and I get
it I get the fact that we spent 100
billion dollars White House finally
confirms they spend 100 billion dollars
on Ukraine and we send 700 a family to
Maui which is absolutely pathetic and
it's still you know it's been a month
already whatever the timeline's been
yeah we'll eventually get to it what do
you mean we'll eventually get to a
couple thousand kids will listen
but that that that desire to say nope
that's it nothing no foreign policy no
need what we're talking about here is
we're talking about our involvement in
Foreign Wars that's not to say that we
shouldn't be doing business yet so I
said strategic Partnerships with people
that are overseas well I get that but
what I'm saying is he asked the question
if we allow China to attack Taiwan
you're like nope we're not doing
anything we're not sending our man over
there I'm not saying I'm not I'm not
sending a single so you're okay if we
lose all the manufacturing oh that's not
necessary that's not necessarily going
to be the conclusion there's a lot that
could happen in between there's a lot of
negotiations that contain place this is
why you have ambassadors that go over
there what I am saying is that if I were
president and I'm not okay and obviously
I'm sitting here giving you the Owens
Doctrine off the cuff but obviously
you'd have to sit down and this is why
you build a cabinet and you have people
that are smarter than you in the cabinet
talk about these things you bring in the
best business guy to talk about how you
get around this but what I am saying is
that I would not be sending a single
American son or daughter to die on
foreign Soul so what about money though
because I agree with you we don't need
to be involved I mean everything that
we've done on post-world War II has been
a freaking disaster Vietnam Korea
Afghanistan Iraq now Ukraine but we
don't necessarily have boots on the
ground per se I know there's allegedly
people there but money or even soft
power or influence or you talked about
diplomatic relations there has to be a
little Nuance it can't just be like zero
we're done fine with diplomatic
relations that's actually what I'm
saying is that we need more diplomatic
relations is the whole point you know
and and we need to stop strong arming
and and making these stances and sending
billions of dollars and with no
accounting by the way and things of that
nature but I think they missed like a
couple of years yeah like a month ago
two months ago the girl from The
Pentagon was like yeah we had a mistake
and there's six billion dollars we don't
know where there is really rich then
north of Richmond Rob if you can pull up
this article because she she made a
comment which I think is perfect time to
ask her about this so uh U.S news no no
this is great U.S news just came out
with this article saying America first
question mark the best countries in the
world according to Americans okay I
don't know who they have out these polls
from but again the annual best countries
ranking by the U.S news the United
States dropped to number five from
number one as determined by
perception-based analysis of over 17 000
respondents worldwide
however when considering American
respondents alone the ranking improved
with the top three countries being UK
they went up eight plus eight New
Zealand went up six and U.S went up to
the U.S ranked number two for attributes
like entrepreneur Spirit strong consumer
Brands easy access to Capital culturally
significant entertainment and being a
place people would live American
respondents also viewed their country
are more favorably in areas such as
affordability plus 38 spots Scenic
Beauty Plus 37 spots racial Equity plus
27 spots and environmental concern plus
two spots compared to Global perceptions
Americans viewed their country as less
transparent in government practices
minus 61 spots wow business practices
minus 39 spots and less favorable packs
environment minus 27 spots wow and
income equality minus 21 spots so
Americans viewed their country wow their
country do you think America is still
the greatest country in the world
do I think that America is still the
greatest I think America has always been
the greatest Amer experiment in the
world
um and experiment with freedom and uh
right now I would say that we are
failing in like I said our country is in
Decline and I think every person can
admit that uh and many times I ask
myself whether or not it's an illusion
you know whether democracy is an
illusion whether freedoms are an
illusion and I think especially coming
out of covid we really saw how unfree
America was and how really it's become a
bureaucracy there's just a bunch of
bureaucrats in DC that are running
everything and so what America was
supposed to be as established by the
founding fathers yes I think that is the
most incredible Vision that has ever
been brought forth the American
experiment and I that is what I fight
for every single day it's the reason why
I get up out of bed because I know that
it's possible for us to get back there
and it starts with everybody becoming
disillusioned do you agree with this one
guy named Joe is I think his name is
Joseph Biden I don't know if you know
this guy or not I don't think he knows
who's this guy is I think he has no idea
you're right by the way we can play clip
if you can play this clip of is it Kirby
if you Pat before you pay the clip yeah
just asked Candace because you're best
known for that line that they said about
you on Fox News born and ran made in
America yeah you see these polls you
know UK I can tell you that UK is not
number one based on personal experience
um what would you say are we still the
greatest country in the world I I say
100 we still are but at the same time uh
I'm I'm the I'm The Optimist I'm the
synergist who's extremely paranoid
naturally I mean startup entrepreneur
I'm a paranoid guy that we have to
constantly fight to keep it together and
call out [__] the best part about
what's going on right now with America
is you know the number used to be 40
immigrants now we have 51 million
immigrants it's the number one data to
look at when you look at what country is
the best country in the world why do we
dominate the world in Immigration people
still want to come here not other places
for me if the country is so bad why are
still people wanting to come here not
other places now we're weak well it
could be because our borders are wide
open on the bottom I agree with that you
can't get into Japan they don't care if
you're born and they live there they're
like you're never becoming I said well
guess what you got a lot of other
options to go to people surf on the
Middle East they dream about coming to
America people still from you know uh
Russia other place still want to come
here China's net migration is in the
negative they're losing I think they
because I think it's because we control
and that goes speaks to the poll that
you mentioned about cultural
significance I think that we dominate
Hollywood we dominate the media and they
have an idea of what America is and I
think probably when they get here it's
not what they thought so what would be a
better country what are you saying that
like I'm just trying to think of why
people want to get to America because at
one point we were those things it's kind
I always liken it to what I thought Los
Angeles was gonna was gonna be before I
got there
life I was like dreaming to go to Los
Angeles yes I was like Hollywood oh my
God amazing and then when I had my first
trip out to L.A horrible I was like
there's like a dilapidated South
American city yeah I would say let me
give you another perspective on this to
be thinking about in America you still
have 50 options okay you can live in
America and have 50 choices meaning you
don't like California go to Florida by
the way Newsom has to answer the
question why under your watch the
greatest State lost people since 1851
and why are they still losing money why
is it that data comes out showing the
AGI the top 10 highest tax states in
America lost 341 billion dollars of tax
revenue and the bottom lowest tax states
gained 341 billion dollars you have to
make the argument so in America you have
options to go different places I can go
to a different region and have to have
low regulation you know people in
Florida are complaining about the fact
that teachers the teachers who are woke
they're not protected in Florida great
go to California totally okay with that
so that's the thing about America
because it has the Constitution set up
the way it is you can compete and if you
don't like the policies in a state
there's still another state for you and
if you want to you know find a way to
improve run for office do something
about it you can change but you know
these things there's options in America
Tom I think you're going to say
something yeah and I
the story we're talking about the
ranking you have to understand how these
rankings are done this is the media
putting together this ranking asking
people about 20 questions what do you
think about America for sports for
economy for Scenic Beauty all these
things and then they make the ranking
together Americans did not say I have UK
number one New Zealand number two and
USA number three first of all if I
showed most Americans a map of the
Hawaiian islands and I said which one is
New Zealand they'd pick one
so you know let's talk about reality but
you understand they make a ranking out
of this and then U.S news not known for
Centrist values comes out and says
Americans ranked no Americans didn't
rank they asked they asked a bunch of
perceptions and they put together
basically a golf score and America ends
up in third place and so I think that
there's also things are going going on
like that for the media is trying to
find ways to kind of propagate this we
ain't so good and I'm I'm with you in
the vision I have tremendous hope and
confidence in the future do I think that
there needs to be bottoming points like
when an alcoholic Uncle reaches the
bottom and decides he's going to change
I think countries need those bottoming
points I still think this is the
greatest place I agree that it's the
greatest parchment ever produced in
terms of the American experiment but I
also think that right now we have a ton
of issues and number one is we can't
have our own National you know media
trying to find the good in it instead of
gleefully talking about a stack ranking
which if Americans had actually spent
one day in London they'd come back home
and they'd be voting us this is this is
where I was going with Candace before
you asked me about how I felt about it
sorry to rant no I loved it has to be
expressed I'm totally okay with that no
what I was going to ask is uh uh Joe is
being Kirby's being interviewed and
being asked about hey how do you feel
about what Joseph Biden is where the
president's comments he's making all
this other stuff and you know he says
the biggest issue in America is white
supremacy what do you think the biggest
issue in America today is oh gosh the
white supremacist doesn't Never Gonna
Let It Go they're never going to let it
go I think I've testified twice in on
hearings where they are trying to tell
you that white supremacy is the biggest
issue the hate crime hearing where you
just ruined everybody you fact checked
everybody in real time Jerry Nadler
everybody was like uh you had everybody
stung which was amazing people haven't
seen it and that's infuriating because
it I remember I said in my congressional
testimony if I had to make a list of 100
things that were impacting Americans
white supremacy wouldn't make the list
and I mean that seriously
um gosh what would be first that's a
very good question I can I can give you
a few things that are ranked very
importantly but I don't want to say what
I would say is is first but the family
unit being destroyed is is if it's not
one it's two
um what what's happening with families
and you know the government's creeping
into our homes in regards to you know
making people believe that marriage is
not aspirational that only happens in a
society that's heading towards Marxist
ideologies and that that is literally
the Karl Marx Doctrine right that if the
government if the government wants full
omnipotence it has to break down the
family unit because the family unit
stands in opposition uh to government
omnipotence so I would probably say
every ill that we're seeing in society
right now that which you might think are
unrelated are actually all related to
destroying the family unit so sometimes
you say you know why are they on this
climate change thing and then you go why
are they fighting trans bathroom signs
and what's with this lgbtq stuff if you
look at examine all these issues and you
realize what they have in common it's
that they are attacking families so
climate change they're telling children
don't have kids don't have kids it's
irresponsible the planet's not going to
be here for 10 years Megan and Harry got
an award because they agreed to only
have two kids it's about the shrinking
of the family unit which is it's totally
bizarre the lgbtq stuff if kids are
chopping off their parts
you know there's no nuclear family unit
if it's two lesbians or two two gay
people more power to the government
you've got to turn to the government to
even have a child which is is now coming
down the pipeline with all of those
things
um and so yeah when I examine every
issue that we're fighting you can see
that what the government is actually
doing is trying to interrupt the family
unit so I would say that that's the
number one issue their friend Larry
Elder said the exact same thing you put
that at number one they put number one
right and then he I mean obviously a guy
like that I want to see what else she's
going to say let me see what else she's
going to say what else would you say
well so I was saying like I would put
family issues first because every other
societal ill follows it you know so when
we're even when I'm talking about the
education system right and and what's
going on and kids are getting
systematically Dumber across Baltimore
they can't find a single child that's
proficient in reading and writing but
talk to the kid about BLM and they're
going to be like oh yeah no absolutely
they're training little marxists the
kids actually know nothing they're
essentially toddlers like when you see a
toddler throwing a temper tantrum they
don't understand why and and so they
just blame rich people right it must be
because of rich people that I failed in
life no it's because you literally
couldn't pass a basic reading exam them
and you were your life was cut off for
you before you even graduated and but
when you look at that again it brings
you back to the family unit uh culture
is a major problem Hollywood and culture
is is definitely up there and but
they're again reinforcing the breakdown
of family the overt sexualization the
perversion I mean that's what I'm saying
about not importing American values that
is one of the most I would say that is
the most disgusting thing right now
that's happening in America is is this
this the over sexualization of our
culture and I look at other countries
and I'm like no I'd much I'd much rather
be importing those values right why what
are we exporting right now when you look
at what celebrities are endorsing and
the
um sexuality obviously you brought up
that I did the whatever podcast it broke
my heart to sit across from a 22 year
old who sleeps with 10 men a night and
her answer is well I make money you know
yeah I make I make a hundred thousand
dollars a year you're 22 years old and
you look like you're you're possessed by
by a demon because you are right there
our culture is demonic and
um where would you put feminism on this
because that's essentially what it comes
down to the family the monetization and
the sexualization and the
commoditization is the number one attack
on family right I mean what are they
telling women men ain't [__] you know
you don't get your back girl you don't
need your back yeah that kind of that's
disgusting you shouldn't be having
children there's a whole culture called
dinks on Tick Tock dual income no kids
yeah you know they're getting millions
millions of views my life is so great I
don't have this is literally the
simulation right now that women are
existing under and believing that uh
that they shouldn't be that men are are
crap and and by the way there's a
response to that which we can talk about
I talk a lot about masculinity and the
decline of masculinity because feminists
have been bashing men over the head
about being men and how men don't have a
lot of leaders and people that they can
rely on and so we're just now kind of
seeing a response to the hyper feminine
feminization of culture which is what we
are suffering from right now we are
living in a major the illusion is that
it's patriarchy it is in fact a
matriarchy everything that we are
dealing with right now is because people
are emotional women have power women are
positions of power and they're women
we're we are more emotional than men
most women are more emotional what about
someone like Chelsea Handler so I do
another show when I'm not doing pbd this
does it discusses this exact same topic
right and
Chelsea Handler like attacked me I went
back at her we went back and forth and
you know she's like this is what an
alpha yeah but you don't think it's
flirting I think it was Hardcore
flirting you know I mean those uh 50
year old uh
alcoholic uh drug addicts if you're not
married yet but I thought that was like
that one you've gone to to you've been
not so kind and you went to war with
Sarah Silverman the Chelsea Handler
these almost 50 year old women who could
have had any guy they wanted in their
20s beautiful smart intelligent what
have you you obviously chose a totally
different path started snorting feminism
and the 100 lives are and you consider
yourself a Trad wife I would assume yeah
you somehow have this balance of being
you know beautiful but also intelligent
but also a mom and also a career woman
like so essentially what's your message
for women out there can you actually
have it all do you kind of have to pick
the Trad wife to prioritize yeah you
need to prioritize and I think the
answer for most women is it prioritize
your family no question no question you
know there are some women that I would
say I met this girl and she probably
shouldn't be a mom right but the truth
is is that that your greatest superpower
that you will ever tap into the I have
never been more confident in who I am
more sure of myself than since I became
a mother you know getting married and
becoming a mother can I give you a
little maybe pushback if you had to
choose one meaning three kids Candace
political points you'd give it all up
just to be on my heartbeat yeah why
don't women understand that exact same
topic because it's not talked about
culturally because I'm considered
Counter Culture right that's not
mainstream how are you saying that how
how dare you say that women are being
told that they should be like men by the
way we're getting the worst end of the
deal I don't know who sat down and had
the feminist meeting in the beginning
and was like Hey so here's how we're
really going to make men lose first
we're just going to keep sleeping with
them with no commitment right we're
gonna just there's gonna be posts right
yeah oh men are really gonna hate that
we're gonna trick them and then we're
gonna be naked on the internet all the
time we're just gonna put our boobs out
there we're gonna fight to free the
nipple men are really gonna hate that
we're also going to work our asses off
just like men yeah and then we're gonna
say we're gonna work just like you and
we're gonna bring in the same men are
really gonna I don't know this is the
worst deal ever I'm like wait wait do
you mean to tell me that there was a
time where we got to just be at home and
cook and hang out with other women and
raise our kids and somebody ruin that
bring me that woman yeah do you think
you know like get on top of that men get
to compete in your sport yeah and that's
okay that's a noble that's Noble
supported that women yeah
they say like progressives one you know
you can't stop something as it's
progressing is this the one issue that
you think can regress like women will be
like you know I don't know how many
women are like that's it I'm going back
to the home I'm putting my apron on I'm
gonna be a good wife I think you
actually think that's realistic though I
do I think it's happening because what's
what we're getting to now is the end of
that overt sexualization period And I
always say to people I'm like examine
the women that are telling you that this
is going to bring you happiness who who
are the women that are out there that
have told you that this is the way to go
where are their lives right now are they
are they are they married no multiple
partners yes by the time they get to
Chelsea Handler's age and why I always
use her as an example is because I was a
huge fan of Chelsea Handler when I was
younger I thought she was so funny I
always watched Chelsea Lately and um I
bought all of her books and you know
obviously she she wrote extensively as
she actually wrote about her multiple
abortion things of that nature so she
had a chance at family and she chose
against it because she decided that she
was going to be young and beautiful
forever and she isn't and wasn't going
to be young and beautiful forever right
and so Chelsea Handler's perfect example
because when you play with feminism for
too long and you can't go backwards it
inevitably ends with Xanax and wine and
prescriptions
um and misery and now trusty Handler is
realizing that biology is always going
to Trump sociology in the end and the
end biology sits back and it wins right
father time is undefeated right it's
it's literally it wins and so now she's
got nothing to nurture and what happens
is those women then start looking for a
social philosophy a social justice
movement that they can try to turn into
the son and daughter that they don't
have right I'm like do you do and does
anybody really think Chelsea Handler
cares about like Dylan Mulvaney being
allowed to go into the right bat no of
course she doesn't nobody could care
that much about Dylan Mulvane I mean
when I heard her crying on her podcast I
was like you need a child so bad yeah
Adam's yeah
um Candace last question on this topic
where do you draw the line meaning all
right so women should go to High
obviously women should go to college you
went to college okay you go to college
for what reason to get a return on your
investment to get a job okay I get a job
I'm making money you said you paid back
150 Grand in students you never did
you've made something in your career I
made a mistake you made a career should
have waited but like wait are you
telling are you saying that women
shouldn't go to college like I
interviewed this guy Nick Fuentes if you
know who he was communications director
for Kanye which I'm sure we could talk
about but he said women should not go to
college they shouldn't even finish High
School basically just because most
people should not go to college okay I
was trying to make that very I'm with
you not women or men it is what are you
going to college for I went to college
because there was a peer pressure
campaign in high school if you don't go
to college you're going to be a failure
and I think that that's the reason most
people go to college is because the idea
of being the kid that goes to Community
College is not it means that you're the
kid that's a loser and failed everybody
signs up for loans with money that they
don't have which marries you further to
the state you know Sallie Mae launched
the ones that I took out which were
greetings I didn't understand anything I
was signing because I didn't come from a
wealthy family I was first generation
college kid I was completely taken
advantage of and started my life in Mass
debt for a journalism degree is that
does that sound like something that any
person should be doing it's completely
irrational I actually think there needs
to be a a collapse of the scam of
college you know you people should be
getting internships out of high school
to figure out what the heck they want to
do before they waste a bunch of money on
a meaningless degree the majority of
people are wasting their money I don't
know many people that are using their
actual degree in the real world right
the girls go and they sign up and they
do fashion and marketing design you know
and the guys if you're doing a you want
to be a doctor and you know for sure
that's what I want to do yeah sure go to
college if you have that vision and
you're sure of yourself but right now
the whole College scam is what needs to
go you did a video called College as a
scam it is so it's um you have no idea
how many girls that I talk to an
interview they go to college they
graduate and they become bartenders
we're servers they pay off their debt
I'm like why the hell did you even go to
college like I don't know I was supposed
to but you did a video college is a scam
but you're uh you want your kids to go
to college your girls are going to
college like how do you guys as parents
grow up with what she's saying I've
answered this question a couple times
and I've talked about uh stem and I'm
very clear with my girls and says all
fun stem all fun skills that are going
to be applicable with an appropriate Roi
and you know we have set aside the funds
for their college education and up the
amount twice in the last 10 years so
that we could have enough getting there
and I think the price is a little crazy
but all fun stem I'll absolutely fun
stem you know hey I want to go with my
boyfriend Philippe to the sorbonne and
study art history well I hope this
happened parents are wealthy and cover
you because I will not be so I'll I'll
go that route and also you know I think
you know cardiologists Physicians
nuclear physicists I think none of that
should be self-taught in the garage
specifically nuclear physicists and that
they there's a reason for stem there's a
reason for stem but also Ann Coulter
you'll probably know about this made a
great great Point she said if someone
was graduating high school she said and
the plumber is sitting there in his best
and only suit that he has proudly
looking at his son graduating and said
my son's coming to work for me as a
plumber and says why and the kid says
because I make 60 bucks an hour working
with my dad's company and everybody goes
a plumber makes 60 bucks an hour they
have the kids don't have any idea about
trades this is where I think in terms of
Gap years Israel gets it right because
you have service of country and you have
disciplines that come out of that and
they all don't stay in the military but
they sure as hell come out with
disciplines and appreciation for no
question about that that's right no
question absolutely so you have boys and
girls yeah so do you have a different
approach with what you would say to the
to Tico and Dylan versus same answers
Tom gave I'm on the same page as Thomas
okay for me if the Dylan plays Sports
and he looks like he's going that route
he gets a scholarship to play sports and
he wants to go to the next level play
professionally it's a completely
different discussion wants to go to
movies and Patrick wants to go to movies
and stuff like that we're already
talking about that Senna in Brooklyn
Brooklyn's personal wants to do it
animated David and the family she's
ridiculous how animated she's sent as a
princess she's Santa's gonna do whatever
she gets the world from me I want to
transition from this story out Rob if we
can do this okay so uh uh you know Joe
Biden impeachment comes up everybody's
talking about it very emotional day for
a lot of people frustrated that this is
going to be taken I couldn't sleep last
night and you know this clip if you can
play this representative Scott Perry on
Biden's impeachment inquiry and what the
reaction to this was if you can just
play this I don't want to get your
reaction to this go forward yes ma'am
what actual evidence do you have as
opposed to allegations to show to the
American public that would Merit an
actual impeachment inquiry of Joe Biden
and prove that today isn't just about
some of you oh I don't know
McCarthy for the sake of enacting
political Revenge this isn't about
political Revenge we have the bank
accounts we can see ma'am you can see
that the homes that the vines own can't
be afforded on a congressional or Senate
salary you also understand that it's not
normal for family members to receive
millions of dollars from overseas
interest those things aren't normal
that's not normal to have 20 cell shell
Country Companies these things are not
normal and it alludes to not only just
widespread corruption but money
laundering if not influence peddling
itself and we also have the president on
the vice president at the time on record
saying that the prosecutor was fine well
son of a [__] the prosecutor was fired
right because the prosecutor was going
after this the company that his son was
working on that's what we have if you
can't see that if you want if you are
that blunt look I'll turn it over the
attorneys I can't see that they think
go back five seconds
she's exactly right you don't report on
it it's crazy if anybody's saying that
there's no evidence of corruption you
you really just have to have your head
in the sand at this point and it's very
frustrating because those people do
exist it's there are people that are
fully and utterly brainwashed I'm so
fatigued by it I mean I barely cover it
on my show anymore because it's like if
you need more information to show you
that this is a corrupt family then
there's there's no more we can possibly
give you you know and Ken's and and you
think anything will happen though do you
think anything will happen to the bidens
no
okay you think they'll get impeached you
think he'll get impeached I don't know
I'm I'm out of political what do you
think Tom I I think they'll get the
motion to the floor remember they saw
about votes and who's got the votes it
doesn't it certainly is not what is the
right or wrong Fair jury answer that's
not the it it's do you have the votes I
think the house may have enough of the
votes to get motions and get up to the
you know to the altar but there will be
no kiss and then the Senate has to
confirm any sort of impeachment we saw
what happened that's Trump when they
when they owned the Senate the
Republicans it's all political Potter
and at the very like worst worst worst
case scenario which I don't think will
happen they'll just make Hunter bun be
the Fall Guy
nothing's happening to Biden and I
actually don't think that anything is
going to officially happen to Trump
unless they want Civil War part two here
so here's my thing and Tom mentioned
hope earlier and we always talk about
this a lot of Americans me included
share that deep frustration right food
feel like hope is dwindling the
Democrats literally wield power get away
with murder the Republicans just are
there like a facade they're just like
they have to be there for for the show
so Candace is is is the system rigged
Beyond redemption or is it still
worthwhile to strive for change
especially for the benefit of the future
generation because people like me can I
see this guy this this is the
Republicans barking the Democrats
nothing is going to happen zero
nothing's gonna happen do you think that
there is hope or we're just this is just
we have to see just videos like this I
definitely share your sentiment and I'm
serious when I say that I just have so
much fatigue with it I'm just like okay
there's gonna be an inquiry and
nothing's gonna happen because nothing
ever happens because if we lived in a
system where it wasn't hopelessly rigged
under Brian would be in prison who do
you know could just smoke crack like
that with a secret service
at the White House I mean like where
where is we're so past rigging and
what's wrong in Morality and ethics that
it's that's why I say the country is
just in full Decline and they're not
even pretending well we we can't figure
out how to put the cocaine in the White
House Let It Go oh God there's no camera
yeah yeah and so it's just it was a time
I think I am just as far frustrated as
you do I think we can correct the ship
yes if I didn't think so I wouldn't get
out of bed in the morning if I thought
that it was completely hopeless I'd be
coming up with the strategy of how to
leave the country
um and I there are good guys there are
there are there are good players there
are people that are well-meaning that
actually do want to shake things up and
change and I will say that we are in
such a better position now when you look
at the independent podcasters that have
these massive followings at the collapse
of the mainstream media you know at the
fact that CNN can't pull in views that I
can pull on my Twitter feed that tells
you that people are awake that the fact
that rich you know Richmond Martha
Richmond is the number one song in the
world right what does that signal to you
it's that okay is it corrupt yes but is
it hopelessly corrupt no because people
are awake to the corruption and I don't
think that's the situation that we were
in in you know five six years ago you
know what the enemy wants to do you know
the two words uh it's called leadership
fatigue factor and Leadership endurance
Factor they want you to get fatigued
they want you to get tired of it and
they want you to stop talking about it
that sound a point and beats an opponent
that's how what happens in boxing that's
what happens in MMA that's what happens
in football that's what happens in
basketball that's what happens in a
fourth quarter and they just look at you
and say they go back and say guys we got
them they're tired it's done now go for
their throat take it all because their
best players are fatigued that's exactly
what they want you to think the more you
think you're fatigued you're tired
you're you're like you don't you're
helpless we can't do anything about it
that's exactly what he wants you to
because in their mind guess what they're
thinking in the third quarter they're
thinking you figure that [__] out
and you're gonna get them
in the third quarter they're worried
about you
and then comes fourth course and no no
guys
we knew they had a chance to beat us but
look at them they're morally and
mentally done we're going to destroy
these guys go run a muck on these guys
and then it's over that's what they're
hoping for so when you said the good
guys who who would you say some of the
good guys are by the way I'm curious I
mean culturally I think that we're doing
everybody's doing I think what your
podcast is doing is amazing I think you
know just getting men to feel that they
have a place in this world you know and
I'm talking about the cultural gains
that we have made
um outside of the political realm which
is a lot of people say do you want to
run for politics no I think the impact
that I'm having in culture is more
important you know I think it's
important people that are leading women
down the right way and you'd have a
massive support oh my God I think you
would have an army behind you and he
meant and he mentioned it and Kenneth
actually wrote this down so you're an
excellent Communicator unwavering
patriotism you generally do
entrepreneurial Spirit you have a
commanding presence given all those
amazing qualities I know Pat kind of
asks obviously I would I would not even
love it I would vote for a person like
you is see seeing what they are doing
and did to Trump influence you not to
enter that Arena like is it would that
be one of those moments because you
didn't say yes or no you kind of were
iffy seeing what they did to a guy that
genuinely cared you even said to
yourself you saw him make that speech
you fact checked and you're like wait a
minute they're lying the guy is actually
real did does that what you're seeing
that because they run the doj and
they're all FBI does that change your
your mindset because you would you would
kill it I don't fear them I don't fear
them at all and I think that what they
want is for you to fear them and I also
think that because they're doing this to
Trump they just can't keep doing this
you know so they they've shown us so
much they've revealed so much of who
they are in the Trump years and in many
ways Trump became the sacrificial
outside lamb uh and he's had to endure
more than I think most people have to
endure in the future I mean you can't
they can't just keep coming out with
like allegations that they did with
Trump when he came you know the whole me
too thing you can't do that what if a
vague's gonna run you're just gonna say
that like 52 women also were raped by
the Vegas once you do the Absurd Thing
Once you can't just keep doing the
Absurd thing so in a way he's kind of
taking all of these bullets and making
it actually easier for people in the
future but I I truly genuinely love what
I think it's more important to win
culture I think it's more important to
fight on the molecular level I think
it's more important to speak to women
about re-establishing the families
that's the that's the war that the
government has actually largely won
thanks in large part to the the public
school system and their Stranglehold on
Hollywood you're not allowed to be a
conservative in Hollywood this is you
must be in lockstep you need to be
influencing these principles these ideas
I can't one young Hollywood actress or
actor that is conservative not one here
I had left older you could go Clint
Eastwood or what's your buddy that um
John Boy John boy yeah like Woods
there's nobody under 30s no they slide
into my DMs and like I agree with you
but I always have a career that's how
scary it is oh yeah I would be told
Candice like I'd be performing in
Hollywood at Big comedy clubs and I do a
trump funny kind of giving him credit
but showing how ridiculous the situation
is and the the manager would be like Yo
dude you can't you didn't hear the like
they don't like the Trump and I'm like
what like don't talk don't do Trump
jokes brother you're in L.A
guess what do you mean hold on people go
on to me after the show like dude that
was freaking hilarious like I I had a
Persian guy once go I couldn't laugh
because my wife is like everybody's
enamel but couldn't laugh it's from he
couldn't laugh his wife and talk about
demasculating man get him and laughed
and and so this my question I want to
ask um just going to my to a point is so
Ken is the a fox poll came out that the
African-American support for Biden
dropped 30 and actually went up 12 for
for Trump do you think that there's like
that type of Change is Gonna have like
meaningful impact for like the next for
the for because he's gonna obviously run
in 2024 do you think that'll make an
impact for her I've always said that I
don't know how long it's going to take
but since Trump got into office I knew
that we were going to start to see black
Americans go away from uh the Democrat
Party I mean that just made sense to me
especially black American men I think
they're really awake to these sorts of
things right now and I think that is in
large part because there is this kind of
pro-masculine movement that's happening
and the the Democrats are really just
the left is offering this culture where
you got to kind of to be a wimp you know
you do men have to be a wimp you know
you have to let the women have to lead
and you just need to shut up and I just
think that black for black men that's
just not going to be a thing and I think
that there's something that they're
gravitating towards being conservative
principles which by the way black
Americans we're all conservative we just
don't know it it's just I'm serious okay
I believe but they focus on just the
issues
but they better they better strike while
the iron's hot because the only
candidate out there that I think black
Americans would gravitate towards is
Trump so if they don't do it now in four
years whether it's uh DeSantis whether
it's God forbid Mike Pence like Mike
Pence ain't grabbing Black America like
I don't think there's a wider guy out
there so it better happen now we were
talking about this attack on masculinity
and what they did with Trump and he's a
sacrificial lamb
um you know the face of masculinity
these days arguably is who Andrew Tate
right yeah and so I was really
interested in speaking with Andrew Tate
I know you guys had him on this podcast
too because you can debate whether or
not you think what he did in his history
should he should account for it now and
you know he was involved in all these
things I get it I get it tens of
millions of men follow him okay your
opinion about his past means nothing I
need to understand this right I I am the
person I think it's really stupid and it
it defies logic when people say that oh
this person has tens of millions this
means that all tens of millions of the
people that are following him must be
racist must be misogynist must be human
sex Chopper I mean you're just not even
trying to think or trying to understand
the culture moment I am way too
interested to come up with an assessment
like that you know tens of many people
are not following Trump because they're
racist that's stupid okay so you're
missing something and you should be
interested in what it is that you're
missing tens of millions of young men
and grown men are not following Andrew
Tate because they hate women okay that's
a very stupid shallow assessment they
want more women to be honest exactly and
so and when I started realizing the
people that were following him you know
college graduates men that are
interested in business uh what the
Hustler University was all about I
wanted to under I wanted to speak to him
and what I've realized is he is a direct
cultural response to 10 years of men
being told that they are not [__] from
women right the Lena Dunham's the girl
culture Taylor Swift with 10 an army of
10 girls every song is about a guy and
why men suck I mean there's the world
girls who love the world Beyonce girls
have been a like a decade the futurist
from Hillary Clinton you know men just
shut up me too movement a decade of men
being told that they have no value no
value in this Society okay it is
inevitable because I believe in
equilibrium right because I believe that
eventually the world has to correct
itself the energy has to correct itself
that there was going to be men that
started saying actually
you do have value
actually that woman has no value
actually women ain't [__] right you know
because she's a hooker because she's a
sex worker and this is what we're seeing
right now and to people that don't
understand that it's because you're
you're pretending that we haven't been
existing under a matriarchy or I'm
actually longer than 10 years I mean
it's been about 15 years of sustained
trash talk to men that has just been
circulated in the main shamita and the
best part about it which is just so
brilliant you gotta love women because
we can be Machiavellian is that at the
same time that we're doing this we're
claiming that we're the victims
it's like and also like me too and
time's up but like we're completely
dominating The Narrative for the last 15
years
um and so I understand it I get it and
I'm actually so happy that men are
starting to talk about what it means to
be a high value man and to bring in a
high value woman right and so is Andrew
Tate the perfect person who uh you know
that in his past and says no he's got a
lot of things in his past and I and I
said to him when I interviewed him you
know I think he should just be
forthcoming and
um have humility and admit the mistakes
and he did a little bit of that in the
interview he said he looked I showed him
some old clips of himself and he
genuinely was not happy to speak
genuinely you could see it on his face
like embarrassed that this is who he was
10 years ago speaking because I've
changed people can improve people can
change let him change because what an
asset he would be you know to uh he he
has these men that are following him
allow him to evolve allow him to be
sorry allow him to make changes and
don't be above anything else stop
discounting all of those young men that
are coming from broken homes that are
directionless and that are being told
that they have no value that are
following him fully agree one more point
with this the high value man you said
high value man high value woman I think
it's very easy to define a high value
man a man who's protector provider
present for his woman respects people
physically fit on the outside morally be
correct on the inside obviously makes
money men of status it's easy to find
that's not a problem how would you
define a high value woman though
especially these days is it beauty is it
social following is it just being a
mother like what's a high value woman I
think it is a woman that wants to be the
CEO of the home I think it is being
aspirational I think it is allowing men
to lead I genuinely believe that that is
the dynamic that works like my husband
leads in our household you know that is
that is just the way that it works you
know
um uh I think it is being beautiful it
is an element of it that part of what
the feminist rinsing tried to do was to
you know the Lena Dunhams don't shave
your armpits that's part of the page
that's disgusting you know like make
yourself less attractive you know is
because men like attract okay you think
you're going to convince men to like
ugly women if we just make ourselves
ugly it's like trying never gonna happen
yeah it's like you're trying to make
somebody say like eventually you're
gonna make them love disgusting food
like you know you know of course people
you should be attractive you should take
care of yourself but it that shouldn't
be the number one focus on Instagram
trying to be sexy it's also being
conservative a men like mystery it means
I cannot imagine how any man thinks it's
attractive for their girlfriend or for
their wife to constantly be naked on the
internet and available to other men it's
gross you know and so that's what I tell
women men men want to wonder about you
you know if you don't want to put
everything out there sure if you do put
everything out there remember want to
sleep with you they're biologically
wired that way absolutely you can get a
man to slide into your DMs and want to
sleep with you but you are not life
material and he knows that yeah like
like Logan Paul's situation can you like
can you imagine like because I I don't
know none of the history I saw him go
down on his knee and he's proposing and
she's like excited and there was that
moment and then you just see all the
slew of every guy and everything video
what do you think about that okay I'm
getting a very nuanced take on that
situation and I and I think it's a
lesson for women
um so I actually loves Nina Agdal I
follow her on Instagram because I I I
didn't know her youth until Dylan dance
just kind of dropped it I knew her I'm
very into fitness and she has this thing
called like the AG doll method and so I
started following her she was super
pretty and doing all that stuff and then
obviously this battle between Logan and
him got real and he starts dropping this
and this is what I say to women you know
unfortunately for her she put on an
entire record because it's popular to
talk about [__] and to be you know this
is what I'm saying it's like this is
this is a feminist simulation like oh
it's hot talk about your partners and
talk about how you like [__] and you
know how you don't have a gag reflex I
mean so crass I had never seen these
clips so crass for her to say
um and she did this because it's cool
and it's relevant when you're young and
in your 20s and you're a part of the
free the nipple you know simulation and
then now it diminished her value it did
and that's the truth and this is this
should be a warning and a lesson for
women and she's obviously being honest
and how humiliated she is and how she
thinks it has impacted her life it has
impacted her there's no question Logan
does not marry her
I don't think there is going to be a man
that does not take this into account I
mean the videos are it's ridiculous it's
ridiculous do you think he will
I think he probably feels responsible
for what happened to her so he might he
yeah I actually don't think it's as bad
as as I know Nina she's from Miami she's
dated actually two of my very good
buddies like it's not like some girl I
met like she did two of your buddies oh
yeah Reed and Patrick one's a famous DJ
one's a big realtor you've met one of
their partners and now Dylan's gonna
drop there we go now here goes the
photos oh they're already out there
they're already out there and these guys
are good dudes good looking dudes I
believe that she's just a sign of our
times feminism liberalism she's also a
social climber before she dated Logan
Paul you know she did Leonardo DiCaprio
Adam Levine there was allegedly some
stuff with we all know now of course but
my point is this she's also a Sports
Illustrated cover model she's actually a
good person yeah she's she's like you
said that you were a fan Dylan danis is
doing her super dirty now that she has a
a court restraining order whatever going
on like that but I'll give you this this
goes back to your point
there's so many girls way worse than
what she's oh of course so many girls
way worse this is this is what I'm
trying to say to him like what this
matters I mean I I was very surprised by
stuff that she has said and I think she
said it to be funny and that's supposed
to be like a girl's being open about
their sexuality but men don't want that
it's extremely embarrassing to a man to
look at videos of your wife talking
about gag reflexes your soon-to-be wife
talking it's really important great case
study I will tell you because it's a
phenomenal case study forever parents
phenomenal case study on what all the
other girls worldwide right now watching
this laugh and doing whatever they're
thinking you can either do it to get
eyeballs like oh my God I can also do
that let me make a video about you know
in the morning and all or you can say
hey man I can't have something like this
because this thing's going to come back
up to me one day and I'm gonna have to
face this mothers you know imagine
bringing that girl home to your mom and
your mom seeing this trending like I
would they're gonna know even even
though at first they're going to be like
you know I really like her yeah and if
you know who she's that he's dating this
girl let me look wait do you know who
this girl is yeah that girl but this
girl that guy I have to say one more
thing though I have to because
let's not forget one thing she's
actually beautiful she's actually fit
she's not some like only fans model
she's not a prostitute that's not a
[__] and like let's forget she actually
is conventionally beautiful on the other
hand look at lizzo yeah you want people
to be like lizzo lizzo has no dirty
videos out in the video yet she's the
definition of freaking Beauty I guess
no no no no have you seen her Instagram
she does she's absolutely no meaning
like and you know porn videos what
should men idolize someone like Liz oh
no and that's why Nina is actually a
great case study because she doesn't
she's not on only that's the pool
and she still suffers consequences yes
no I told you I like her I've followed
her like I think I agree with you I
think she's beautiful fit all of those
things but the bigger point is that
she's not even a prostitute and look at
how all this is coming back to Hometown
and Pat you you're you know you having
kids and uh Candace you having children
well the other flip side of it is list
and this is going to like a Kim
Kardashian like this girl patch what's
her name the one that started on this
one so she has says she's gonna have
kids one day the internet that doesn't
go away those videos are always going to
be there like the Kim Kardashian a
couple I think about a year ago she was
crying bawling because she's like she
tried to get Kanye tried to buy the
video of the sex tape those kids it's
not going to go away your kids are going
to see them but by the way listen you
want fast success you can do it you want
fast money go sell cocaine you want fast
success make stupid videos of you sex
tapes and release it trust me
immediately you can be famous starting
off with a high school then you can be
famous in a college and then if you're
you know you have some kind of momentum
it could be National nobody's talking
about it depending on who the guys right
but that Fame comes with consequences
and you have to live with that for 10 20
years so if you're okay with that speed
go for it so for her this happening to
her she's not a dummy this is not a girl
that's a dummy uh in America no Nina's
not a dummy Nina knows what she's saying
and what you know the video you're
making stuff like that it's can and at
this point what what's happened there
with the situation her Dylan Logan all
this stuff he he so he has to marry her
wow he has to marry him he has to marry
her there is no now you can marry and
divorce in three years but he has to
marry her now because he will look for
the rest of his life he's going to have
to say Dylan is the one that got you to
leave that guy you're probably right
permanent he has to marry he also has to
beat Dylan in this fight it's the same
face oh he will be you brought up
something I think is super important
you brought up Kim Kardashian that's how
this whole thing started that's the tip
of the spear yes okay with the deal and
yeah everyone will look to her and say
well she did a sex tape now she's a
billionaire yeah okay like the whole
family's been manufactured
um I have obviously firsthand my my best
friend is the guy Chris Humphries that
married Kim Kardashian and I was a
groomsman in the wedding I walked Chloe
down the aisle I saw Kendall and Kylie
when they were 15 16 like Bruce was
Bruce when Bruce was Bruce straight up
Bruce was like so I've seen this way
back I've seen this whole thing play out
and a lot of girls are like I remember
when you did it and like all girls love
Kim Kardashian but don't you think
that's the person that started this
entire thing and she married Kanye yeah
I don't think most girls all these girls
love Kim Kardashian I think actually
what do you mean she's the she has more
Instagram followers she is followed and
she is great at marketing herself but I
I do think that there is now a strong
push back to Kardashian culture I think
that's ending is what I'm kind of saying
I don't see it tell me how you're seeing
it changing
um you know I don't think she is
idolized as she as she was I think that
Kim Kardashian caught that moment of
femininity and sexuality she was the she
is the it girl of what we're talking
about she is the it girl she is the
moment she was talking about sex and
people uh that that's what their show
that's how it became popular who they
were dating you know who they were
sleeping with she's crying about her sex
tape she's crying about this like she
brought forth the sex culture so she is
the the icon from the moment that we're
talking about but I think we are
actually moving away from it and with
Kim she's a great example
she's got tons of money and she's got
tons of wealth you know
what's her personal life
is that it is it just money and wealth
because she's this is her fourth
marriage that's failed am I correct
marriage well she told me she's gonna
have let's be honest who's going to
marry Kim Kardashian she's she's way too
she's way is that the worst the hot tom
look at this here the highest negative Q
score belongs to Kim Kardashian 71. wow
but I'll give you this argument The
Hollywood Reporter it's not just Kim
it's Kendall it's Kylie it's Chloe okay
but then Kendall I think we'll get
married she's actually kind of abstained
from the what
are you talking about
he's quite like she's quiet though she
doesn't really you know she's quietly
dating after the NBA I'll give you that
okay yeah well said but then this is my
point then they all have kids and you
don't think that their kids are going to
be the most famous girls in the world
Adam where are you going with it that
this that she's saying that you think
it's coming to an end well you're saying
that this is going to continue I'm
saying it's one million but but hear me
out this is this is great so
what is going to happen is with this
this case study again life is about case
studies you're gonna study case studies
you go to Harvard to get an MBA what the
hell you think you do for three years
when you get your MBA 500 case studies
when you go to Harvard for three week
program Wharton all you're doing is case
studies four three four years these guys
that go work at Mackenzie Gardner all
these come BCG they only go there
because they have 500 case studies under
their belt that they went through for
whatever Business Degree they got this
is a phenomenal case study for churches
to use this is a phenomenal case study
for schools to use this is a phenomenal
case study for parents to use this is a
phenomenal case study for a lot of
people to use and by the way this case
study is going to inspire some people to
say what you know what you guys are out
of your mind I'm gonna follow what she
did no problem still go ahead and do it
we've been trying to get people to say
no to drugs for a long time people are
still saying yes to drugs okay you know
what do you do hey did you see how many
people died from fentanyl did you see
how many people die from cocaine and
playing know when we used to live in
Plano
kids went to school everybody before one
moved to Plano Tom's Like Pat let's move
to Plano so I'm like okay so we moved to
Plano
I started saying what are you guys
moving to oh we're moving a plane I know
nothing about Plano Texas when I'm in
L.A we're living in Granada Hills or
where were we living at we were living
in uh North Porter Ranch or whatever
Porter Ranch it's like oh you're gonna
go to heroin Plano like
type in plain on heroin rice
that's always the best song Somebody's
like oh you're going to I want a crack
full I'm going to crack Miami after the
coke man so stay there tonight yeah go
to go to okay look back look at the
third story a look back at the Plano
heroin crisis 20 years 20 years ago so
I'm like whatever so kids were dying
left and right you get cheap labor there
that's why I remember but the point I'm
trying to make to you is yeah you're
right some people are going to look at
this and say this is how I'm going to
get Fame and some people are going to
look at this and saying oh my God for
the rest of my life I'm going to get
stuck on this I don't want to stay on
this story I want to move on here's a
story I want to go to Rob play this clip
that you and I saw yesterday play this
clip that you and I saw yesterday from
AI so I'm really curious to know what's
your thoughts are on this so this is a
new technology tracking which one of
these workers at this coffee shop are
working the hardest the AI and it tracks
which customers sit in there the longest
to track so watch this ai go forward
camera does all of this for you Anna's
done 20 cups vikas done 10 cups Elena's
done 10 cups Olga's done three cups so
the boss can come back and say hey Olga
any reason why you sat your ass down for
an hour all you did is three cups all
day you're fired right leaning on the
counter in the back she's doing nothing
in the back and look at how hard Anna's
working so guess what this favors who
Anna deserves a race Olga deserves to be
fired and the 10 cups per day guy
deserve to just get exactly what they're
getting paid they can't ask for a raise
now I'll put the picture I texted you uh
in Congress which is very interesting
this AI Now tracks Which percentage of
these members of Congress stay on their
phones the longest time wow you see name
there 76.9 85.5 61.2 percent 81.2
percent
is this an area of AI where a level of
accountability and surveillance goes to
a level where a boss a parent by the way
parents your kids go to school now you
can see what teachers are doing with
kids you can kind of watch what teachers
are doing with kids you can now track
what your kids are doing in school you
can track this for sports who's
practicing who's training when they go
to the gym imagine a football coach has
AI three hours you're going to the gym
which linebacker is actually training
for how long which one is not you can
now officially track how many reps they
did how many sets they did how many is
this a good thing with this level of
accountability or does this kind of
concern you gosh really hard to answer
right off the cuff but what I will say
is that we are quite suffering from
chronic laziness right now and that
would transform if you knew that you
were being watched when your boss walks
in you kind of stiffen up and you start
doing stuff because you know that you're
you're being watched and because I know
how far
Millennials gen zigo in terms of a
laziness like they do need like a little
kick in the butt maybe this could be the
solution
um by the way regarding schools I've
always thought why can't I watch my kids
while they're in school they have
daycares for daycares you can do that
because they want parents to feel
comfortable about what's happening so
you can log in and you can watch what's
going on that's right this crisis that
we're doing with like kids beating up
their teachers what if they knew their
moms yeah or just watching them from
their smartphones these kids might
straighten up we love that yeah and we
would feel good about seeing it I'm so
okay with like schools being able to
have cameras and letting parents access
that that does not bother me at all
um I think that's a great idea and
that's a great way to use AI too and
teachers would probably be doing less
finicky stuff in the classroom but
there's an element of this that also
feels that's right subhuman yeah like
we're watching like robots like I don't
know like we're suddenly in like uh I am
legend or something was that no iRobot
what is this yeah
I see it if it's like a Starbucks and
you're monitoring for this type of stuff
but then Olga gotta get fired three cups
breaking news
I'm with you because yeah it's cool I'm
kind of creeped out about a little bit
but then like how far do we go like in
China their AI system can if you're
crossing the street and you jaywalk it
doesn't have to see your face if it sees
your body walking it sends it takes
money out of your account already and if
you don't pay it your social score goes
out and if people are hanging out with
you their [__] goes down and it's like
damn this is the beginning of the end
you're a father what do you think about
this oh my God I happen to be married to
a teacher and who every now and then
does parent conferences and data always
wins whether you're the district
attorney or the prosecutor or your
school teacher data always wins people
sit down
and you say hey I'd like to talk to your
kid about math and everything well they
probably need more instruction or
attention from you what's the ratio do
you have an assistant that's in the
class usually you start there and then
it's like here's the Baseline here's the
test they took let's look at the numbers
okay uh what do we have to do
suddenly it flips the switch you know oh
my son my daughter wouldn't do that
let's look at the surveillance camera at
the 7-Eleven okay
um what do we do to keep him out of jail
is there a probation option here
data changes everything that's what
happened this week by the way so I was
in school so I feel very strongly that
that there is a creepy side to this to
government surveillance but you know
what data usually stops arguments and
moves people toward discussion of
Solution that's how I'll add one more
what you're saying is Olga's got to be
fired
yeah
all getting fired it's exactly right and
Olga comes in with an employment
attorney and then we say yeah sir let's
just sit down and look at this and then
he leaves and tells there's nothing I
can do for you yeah
I'll say Candace I think was right this
is neither good nor bad it's just it's a
thing and I equate this to the metaphor
of what social media is or even what
marriage is and I'll say this like you
know the great thing about social media
is everyone has a voice they can say
what they want to say but also the bad
thing about social media is everyone has
a voice that can say what they want to
say so when I talk to people about
marriage like this one answer was so
poignant he goes like what do you love
about marriage like oh I love my wife
you know she's just always there she's
always there for me I go what do you not
like about marriage my wife is always
there and that's exactly what this is is
that like they're just tracking you are
you forced by the way I think at the end
of the day this is this better for
society or Worse would you use it I
would absolutely use it if they were
using it out there right let me tell you
why would you know you ready you ready I
would absolutely use it and tell them
that person that's working the most you
get to come and ask me for massive raise
perfect go for it yeah you get to come
and ask me four race because the video
validates you're working your ass off
and the people that say no you shouldn't
do this and all this stuff no no no no
problem totally yeah but I would walk in
and say and say that and say hey Pat I
think I've been working hard it's a
three percent inflation raise I think I
deserve five to ten why do you think
that it says can we take a look have you
been watching me check the stats yeah
yeah
you want to say something because I
because you know that that in a place to
Pat would I think make people workers
they know they're getting so nobody's
gonna oh [__] I mean it could be good
for such a lazy generator exactly yeah I
actually like it I I like it a lot by
the way I want to spend 30 seconds on
the next story yeah I I had no plans of
covering bad news because we're having
such a good time on the podcast but I
think we have to do this 30 seconds I
think it's necessary
um Mitt Romney says he won't be coming
back for re-election running I didn't
want to ruin everyone's day I know you
guys have a lot of different things
you're you're dealing with and I it's
terrible news we're gonna have to
overcome this collectively together as a
unit I think we're strong enough to do
it we have faced the tougher challenges
in the past before but uh this should be
tough I think we can do it Senator Mitt
Romney not seeking re-election we have
to move on guys we just have to move on
I think we should have a moment of
silence for the people of Utah
half a second we should have it and move
on okay so uh next next clip Rob do you
have the other clip let me see if you
have the other clip on our friend uh uh
Kareem Jean-Pierre uh the the yeah if
you can choose if you can you know she's
black and a lesbian she wants everybody
know that so her Dei score is by the way
and by the way Kansas had this jacket
before she even thought about buying
that jacket
and it said that [__] stole my look
I don't care so Peter Ducey asked is
this a question about uh fossil fuel is
that where she walks off oh she's just
no no no he asks a question uh uh from
uh from her I don't think I don't know
if this is the one or not how recent is
this video by the way go back to it if
it's recent then that's the one this one
is from yesterday okay then this is the
one let's see if she if this is the one
just play Let's see this clip and with
that folks Play My President interacted
with so many of his son's foreign
business associates
there's a question that Peter Ducey asks
about fossil fuel I think it's
absolutely fantastic that he has I'll go
to another story we'll come back to it
we have to cover that story okay
which one do we want to go to let's go
to the story with over half of
transgender prisoners
in Wisconsin are sex offenders obviously
very surprising but uh let's take a look
at this here to see what this is telling
us the story
so a report from Wisconsin Department of
Correction reveals that over 50 percent
of male inmates identified as
transgender females in Wisconsin prisons
have been convicted of at least one
count of sexual assault assault or
sexual abuse out of 161 transgender
identifying male inmates 81 of them have
been convicted of such offenses
including crimes like sexual
exploitation of child rape and sexual
intercourse without consent the
oversight project at the Heritage
Foundation obtained these records and
director Mike Howell emphasized that men
belong with men and men only in prison
he argued that housing sex offender men
who claim to be women with female
inmates is concerning and contributes to
perceived moral decline what do you have
to say about the story I mean least
surprising story ever and I've been
talking about this and there's a
two-prong approach here first and
foremost the advantage of a man you
commit a crime you commit a sex crime
you molest a child and you know how they
treat pedophiles in prison you know how
they treat sexual deviants in prison
she'd say actually no I'm transgendered
uh that's what's actually happening
please put me amongst the women uh
inmates who now need to accept and the
fact that prisons are doing this they're
acknowledging them and affirming them
and that taxpayers are having to Bear
the expense I can't even talk about how
much that infuriates me
um the but the second element of this is
that there is what's not being spoken
about well it's definitely been spoken
about my podcast is the growing alphabet
Mafia
um and how they are now adding letters
that really just imply sexual deviancy
you know what I mean like a man feeling
the need to put on panties a woman's
underwear and you're pretend that that's
like a gender or an identity a perfect
example Sam Brinton the nuclear energy
the White House person who literally was
open about the fact that he was a sexual
deviant wearing heels lipsticks into pup
play which if you look into what pup
play actually is you will be shocked at
how disgusting it is
um you know on a leash and still got the
job you know you used to be fearful that
if they Googled you and you'd find the
stuff online your employer you couldn't
get hired but this guy got right yeah oh
this guy that used to be it that that
used to be a disqualifier if you could
find somebody naked in straps and and to
pup play Sam Burton just outwardly I am
a freak and flying my people high gets
the job what was his job he wasn't ahead
of nuclear waste in the energy
department they gotta go no I promise
you and then guess what happened he's a
clip though got arrested for three times
for stealing women's panties at freaking
airport that guy yes not just one pair
okay
that guy like that would never do
something
what are we supposed to be surprised I'm
sure I'm a freak and then I did some
freaky things right and that's what's
happening right now yeah in this so This
climate of non-binary I'm a man but I
want to wear women's underwear and
before they're telling you that
something is wrong right they are saying
I am flying my freak flag high and then
we're all supposed to be shocked when
they do something that's sexually
deviant and that it's mind-boggling to
me it's why I am that it is an issue
that I care passionately about I am a
mother to young children why does a drag
queen want access to a child can anybody
can I answer that big question okay
you're a man and you like to dress up as
a woman and go to nightclubs okay flying
your free flag hot now you're demanding
access to read books to children does
that not just do we do can we pass the
sniff test guys you know and then you
have women
you know it's you know it's really
interesting we're here we're queer we're
coming for your children you've heard
this before yes let's all say it in
unison guys right I mean it's scary and
here's my thing like for instance like
like you know I we have everybody here
has freaking gay friends I have gay
family members when it comes to like the
pride month and everything it's like
could you talk about the oh the
sexuality of it it's like when is it
ever cool name another month or a day or
a moment where it's cool for any group
to walk outside butt naked g-string and
I get that there's like people are
bringing their kids which I think they
should you know go to jail but when is
it ever cool for you to be in a bike
butt naked yeah why was that totally if
I said hey guys tomorrow's family day
okay we're gonna have a family parade
and we're gonna celebrate families no
person is showing up butt naked right
it's it's nope no family
that's crazy
get naked you know the men that were on
bicycles literally naked right but for
some reason when you say okay it's an
lgbtq Pride Parade you know you're going
to see nudity what does that tell you
and people are fearful to talk about
this and it's it's crazy to me as a
parent that we've allowed this to go so
far that we've allowed sexual deviancy
to be perceived as an identity you know
as you know something that needs to be
treated and loved and who are the people
behind saying we have Allah women it's
always women why don't why do women not
see the Ridiculousness and why aren't
the women speaking out more about trans
men in sports like why don't well
because those women aren't those are
feminists those are the Chelsea handlers
right and so that that's a whole
different simulation it's the moms at
home are not the ones that are pushing
that what percentage of women under 30
best guessed do you think fall into that
type of ideology like feminist yeah like
they love Chelsea Handler they're cool
with this they're cool with men being in
sports difference if you're talking like
early 20s versus end of 20s I'm saying
I'm saying gen Z let's talk about that
25 and under that's the future this is
who we're trying to convince not to go
down this path
you want a percentage
well I know that you've highlighted that
20 of gen Z identifies LGBT look here's
here's a mayor in Burbank he's an
Armenian mayor okay this guy in the
classroom he's having this guy
spank them check this out this is the
Burbank This is the Burbank mayor the
music might be that's the bird what
mayor that's doing this right proud I
mean she's Pro she's a strong Warrior
and he's like what's wrong with that
there's nothing wrong with some of the
craziest tweets came out about this guy
which is absolutely wild when you see
the gust folks posted his uh tweets oh
my God Constantine Anthony out of
Burbank doing this by the way uh here's
Oklahoma Elementary School faces calls
for a firing uh drag queen principle the
principal in Oklahoma is a drag queen
can you please pull this up picture for
us pulled this picture up for us to see
it so calls to fire drag queen principal
Shane Vernon also known as Chantel
Mandalay where moonlights as a as a drag
but then also previously was arrested on
child's porn about 20 years ago yeah and
yeah and basically got away with it
because of a technicality I looked into
this case technicality because they
found what was clear to one judge
another judge was child porn but then
when they brought the trial forth they
couldn't identify the child and so
basically they were like you can't prove
this is actually a child right so they
had to drop I swear yeah because you
have to be able to prove so if I say
that this is a child even if it's
abundantly clear to all this as a child
you have to be able to prove that right
so it was clear enough that they
arrested they arrested him it was clear
enough that a judge said this arrest
holds and then another judge said you
actually have to be able to say who that
child like we have to be able to say
that person is actually a minor and they
weren't able to do this so the charges
got dropped on a technicality right so
he gets this expunge from his record and
then he somehow gets voted in a private
ceremony the the the they came together
no parents were there and they made him
principal years 20 years later child
arrested for child porn charges yeah
which city in Oklahoma
can you show the photo could we just all
be completely honest and all the viewers
out there look how scary three drag
queens are like like some people have
like a clown phobia look how scary that
guy is right there look at look zoom in
on the guy on the right what that looks
like like the penguin from from the
first pictures by the way they're scary
like it's scary somebody who was
arrested for child pornography demanding
access to elementary school children and
they're and they're cool with it yeah
they're cool I don't think anymore
because the story got exposed no no not
the Oklahoma's if you don't know if you
know this is actually the reddest state
in the Union oh really yes West Virginia
Oklahoma Alabama number one the most the
most the reddest state in the United
Boomer Sooners but Pat what you in La
there's a story about uh California
so in California
um
which here it is California passes Bill
punishing parents who don't affirm trans
kids in custody battles okay so if you
don't affirm kids in custody battles uh
Elon called it other Madness California
State Assembly passed ab957 which
mandates that judges in child custody
cases consider whether a parent has
affirmed a child's transgender identity
an amendment in June broadened the
requirements stating the that the
parents must affirm their child's gender
identity to be deemed suitable okay for
the child's welfare in court to which
um critics like Elon Musk we know what
happened with one of his
billion children strongly criticized the
bill must describe it as utter Madness
and warned it could jeopardize parental
custody if parents disagree with their
child's transgender identity so now
California is like penalizing people if
they don't affirm a kid's transgender
transition have you've seen have you
familiar with it yeah I'm familiar with
this and what I've said is that I've
stopped being outraged at California
stories it's like to me it's like if
you're still a parent and you're raising
your kid in California outside of like
you quite literally have no money and
cannot leave the state I I can't
sympathize to you anymore I mean I I
can't I literally can't tip that anymore
it's gotten so crazy there the policies
that they're putting forth that they're
able to push through they're telling you
I mean that is a it's basically a
communist state at this point that
people are basically watching North
Korea be built around them under the
most extreme circumstances and they're
staying there and then they're going oh
my God I can't believe this is happening
it's like California has showed you what
California is it is time to pick up your
children and leave California the state
owns your children already in a variety
of different ways there there it doesn't
it's ending with transgenderism this has
been going on for a very long time you
saw this with covid they want to put
shots in your child's arm you have no
rights in California so I am now
removing your right to complain if you
are if you are still living in the state
of California we can also Ski and Surf
from the same day
I love how people complain about
everything kids when it comes to Cali
the traffic that and they're just like
yeah but the weather I'm like it's not
worth it
the weather in North Korea
so here's my question to kind of wrap up
all the so the feminism the the women
the the making men weak right the the
going after the kids the trans things
they're going up like is it a concerted
effort by like when you hear like the
Klaus and and uh the Bill Gates where
they're like listen overpopulation is is
is is the biggest problem is it an
accident or these guys just openly
telling us because all those people that
we talked about they're not having
children yeah the trans you know I mean
the the weak men they don't want to have
kids anymore the feminists are like we
don't need men is it by accident or is
it an effort to really slow down the the
population like is it is it a deeper
thing I think America's at War I think
America is at War I think that people
always thought World War III would be
something like World War II people would
be dropping nukes and no I think it's
it's a silent War it's an ideological
war
um I believe that there is a globalized
effort to take down America from within
and people realizing after years China
is a huge part of this effort that you
could take over America without firing a
singer single bullet and it'd be it
begins and ends with culture and that's
why I believe that culture is the
biggest battle that we're facing right
now sick and Tick Tock really helps
there I don't think uh by the way I
think that that that fight uh the
feminist fight is is coming to an end
because the product is showing common
sense is winning and data is winning
proving that this is not working and
there's more 60 year old women right now
talking about the biggest mistake they
made is buying into being a feminist
they can no longer have kids they wish
they were married they wish they would
have done this guys I wish you were
right I really do but I spend probably
more time women under 30. yeah and I I
say guys what do you think about this
what do you think about this did these
25 and under women they they are so far
gone and that's the future I wish you
were right you know you know what it is
for for you to say that you also
contribute towards it though because
think about it you're blaming me no I'm
not I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not
blaming no no I'm not telling me I'm not
blaming you there's an element of it
that even you know whatever you want to
change you have to look at it in a
different way and not capitalize off
what it's out there you have to
eventually when I was all I did was
women from you know 14 to 25 that was my
number one priority and I'm like listen
that's all I want to do 26 times a year
I'm in Vegas I was a four hour drive
away from Vegas and Vegas the
opportunity for prospecting was
priceless on what it was this is
pre-tender days I have no clue what it
is to swipe right you have to actually
go talk in Prospect like that was work
like it takes work of going in and
networking and meetings and a friend and
this and eventually to go versus today
it's a DM you're working your numbers
100 messages boom let's go six o'clock
then you got one at eight then you got
one out of ten I don't know that system
it's a completely different ball game I
think it's also an element of
you know us as men we need to also kind
of challenge the status quo and tell
them we're not attracted to this this is
not attractive anymore right on what
you're doing you think this is
attractive we're also not turned on by
this I think we can also play a role in
that but that's a whole different
conversation I don't want to get into it
I want to wrap it up here with your
documentary yeah uh you know your the
the BLM documentary that that you did
the biggest lie ever sold uh phenomenal
when you did that and you're kind of
going through how you know you know from
one lens I'm kind of watching you right
now because I'm watching you as a uh
Talent as an individual to see what
evolution you're you're personally going
through right like hey as you change and
your life changes and you're making
money and you have kids and you get
married and you move you might as well I
used to be interested I'm really not
interested that's not my passion that's
not my fight this is not my fault when
I'm intro and then now you're going into
True Crime you know with the this this
recent one that you did which is uh uh
what's his name Steve Avery Stephen
Avery yeah and what happened with that
so out of all the topics you could have
chosen to do documentary on why this
it's actually a perfect build on
destroying the BLM narrative and it's a
perfect build on who I am and how I got
into this place we started this
conversation by talking about you know
Trump coming down and me not wanting him
to be there and then me realizing that I
was a victim of propaganda my entire
life and so as a cultural Warrior if
that's what you want to call me
um I I am really focused on getting
people to understand that their entire
life could potentially being decided
upon by Propaganda by propaganda's
effort that what they think they know
they don't know and so obviously the
huge tackle in the political climate of
black lives matter was really how I
started myself in politics as it was
like unheard of a black person not
supporting BLM how could you not and
then I needed to show people you know
after the dust had settled this is what
I was saying and now black lives BLM as
an organization is bankrupt and people
watched my documentary they saw where
the money went they realized that they
had been duped because they were
emotional and they were made to feel
guilty because they were white and they
just sent money into a dark hole and
this next documentary is really the same
exact Examination for whatever reason we
set our presets to trusting a
documentary more than the news like
we're like well now I'm getting the real
information because it's a documentary
and there's no way that these two
lesbians from New York who created
making a murderer could possibly be
playing with me
um they must be telling the truth the
villain the villain is actually the hero
in this docu-series super important
first Endeavor really that Netflix made
into docu-series and it largely built
their empire I would say on this story
and Netflix has since continued this
tradition of taking villains and
convincing the public got their Heroes
the Central Park five guilty as Sin
guilty as Sin and yet a Netflix
documentary has made people believe that
they're not guilty of sin uh they've
softened Jeffrey Dahmer you know this is
Netflix's Legacy right this is they what
what are we doing as a culture it's not
just happening
um in the real world you know we're also
seeing aspects of that in the
Fantastical world uh Maleficent you know
forget that story what about actually
she's a person in there Joker he's
actually a human being right we take
these villains and we turn them into
hero and we're facing this cultural
assimilation where people want to
believe that actually the villain has a
heart and so I wanted to dive into the
Steven Avery story because I was stunned
as I when I when I learned the truth
about what happened but there's a larger
thing that I'm trying to express to
people about mainstream media about
Netflix right the power of Netflix is it
is an absolute Powerhouse and it is
forming the way that people think and
this story is kind of where it began and
I thought it was interesting challenge
for me because it wasn't split a lot
long political lines I wanted to do
something that felt a little more
apolitical because it wasn't like
conservatives thought he was guilty and
liberals thought that he was innocent no
conservatives and liberals alike got
duped by this documentary and Netflix
banked and um it's just it's a very
compelling story but the the truer story
is the study of humanity the study of of
propaganda the psychology of propaganda
which I am forever fascinated about yeah
this is I mean when I was watching it
you couldn't stop you're just curious to
know what happened with it did you
follow this story I was watching it on
because and going off your point Candace
so 19 what Netflix when they first aired
the first episode 19 point something
million watching it people like would
not go on dates they wouldn't go with
the friends they would speed home and go
do it so so Ken is you're painting a
different picture to where and I saw the
the one of the females that that started
it she went to school she wanted to be a
director and a writer and everything and
then she was just like she read the
story on a train right she read in a
newspaper and she was like I'm gonna go
in there I'm gonna go to Wisconsin where
it was in Wisconsin right yeah and and
just flip the script and make it
something that people would want to
watch so it's all it's all Bs yeah and
to see people like conservatives that
I've had on the show that were like I
thought that he wasn't guilty you know
it's really yeah because they were good
they did a very good job at making you
think that these people actually are
victims and also can we talk about the
why it really matters when you do this
in the real world you're not doing in on
a Disney movie is because a woman at the
who was victimized by Stephen Avery he
was eventually convicted she was raped
by two men she was shot she was stabbed
she was cut up into pieces and she was
burned in a burn pin she was 22 years
old had her entire life ahead of her and
because of people like Alec Baldwin and
Trevor Noah in a mainstream media effort
and this anti-policing sentiment and
this belief that we have that the
villains could actually be the ones that
are struggling her family then not only
had to bury her this faithful Catholic
Family who handled this in just the most
wonderful capacity given the
circumstances then had to deal with
conspiracy theories because Alec Baldwin
said well her brother wasn't crying
enough so you know so that's part of it
that means that like actually Steven
Avery is innocent so you just imagine
what we do to real people when we recast
the victims as the villains and the
villains as the victims There's real
life consequences to that I I think this
is a media thing that goes on and I was
particularly incense I remember if
anybody remembers when Rolling Stone
magazine uh two weeks after the capture
of the Boston Marathon bomber remember
there were two brothers yeah and one
actually ran over his brother during the
case and killed him and then he was on
the cover of Rolling Stone they were
fawning over him as this attractive guy
who just didn't understand there it is
there it is you know and they portrayed
him as this because they actually
rolling someone won't tell you is they
actually liked the fact that he took
action against what was core America
yeah they actually liked the fact that
he had actually stepped out to do it
there was an undercurrent here where
they were not only making a hero he was
the resistance against the U.S you know
establishment that they wanted to see
and that's that the convicting a
murderer it's the same thing in 2015 the
anti-police sentiment was building so
the reason why Trevor Noah and Alec
Baldwin and all these Hollywood
characters were were jumping on this
wasn't for the same reason people at
home were watching it was because this
was this was the message that was coming
down the pipeline now all of a sudden we
want anti-police the police are the bad
guys the police are crooked this is the
new American shtick so to speak I have a
question you brought up conspiracy
theorists
um this doesn't necessarily have to do
with documentary but it kind of does
because it's on daily wire so in your
most recent episode of Candace Owens you
you kind of threw some shade on the
conspiracy theorists you kind of was
even all the right wing and you were
like on one hand you know I'm a
anti-semitic Kanye supporter but on the
other hand I'm a puppet of Israel of
Israel and Ben Shapiro yeah so which one
is it
people that's so far into their
conspiracy theories the stuff that I
have read about myself it's insane like
literally if you don't place your hands
right even when I'm wearing a t-shirt on
my show yeah with the t-shirt on my show
they'll be like oh what does it mean I'm
like I don't know it's a plane they're
like okay but like what does it mean why
is there an orange and a Concord plane
and I'm like oh I don't know they're
like well because you know people on the
internet will just make something up
it's true literally I have to be
conscious of what I wear I be conscious
of my hand placements they'll say that
I'm in the Illuminati there are
conspiracy theories about my uh
father-in-law who sits in the House of
Lords in the UK that he plucked me works
for the Rothschilds at my marriage to
Sham I mean people I get it I get it we
I get why we don't trust the media and
that's good but there there's also a
level that people will go to trick to
create conspiracy theories and when you
watch commissioning a murderer and we
show you the fandom the fact that this
sick disgusting man with the history of
incest and pedophilia and you know uh
being violent towards women is is
getting
fiance is writing him letters and he has
fiances in prison and people that are in
love with him and crying outside yeah we
got to talk about that we gotta talk
about it he does look like Brad Pitt I
mean obviously he doesn't I'm being
sarcastic to wrap it up guys
go ahead Tom if you got 10 seconds go
for it no I was just gonna say that
um you know conspiracies theorists will
always be around us but truth and facts
eventually come to this reveal
themselves yeah no question about it I
don't care about your feelings Tom so I
don't care all right Candace thanks for
being on Rob if we can make sure once
again folks go watch the documentary
they can find a document or where
dailywireplus.com the first episode's
for free on YouTube if you want to watch
it you'll be hooked you're going to love
it go to dailywater.com you can watch
the second episode the fourth episode
just came out last night and there's
been a huge response to that just every
episode is an absolute bomb you're going
to love it and also I just want to say a
conclusion Olga you gotta get fired
Candace coming up by the way I don't
want to say she's sitting here and she's
pregnant and she's on fire the entire
time zero excuses was just in La flew
out all the way to this other side and
then she's got to get home you're you're
amazing at your work and I love your
relentlessness keep at it have a great
weekend everybody again go watch the
documentary today take care bye bye bye
bye guys
so far